[Musique]
c'est l'heure de mardi politique sur
France 24 RFI bonsoir Frédéric rivière
bonsoir osine bonsoir à tous et ensemble
nous recevons Jean-Louis bourlange
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de l'Assemblée nationale et
député MoDem des hautes scèes bonsoir à
vous bonsoir et merci d'avoir accepté
notre notre invitation alors en France
Emmanuel Macron a appelé à redoubler
d'effort pour parvenir à un cesser le
feu durable dans la bande de Gaza et
samedi le ministre américain de la
défense a demandé à Israël de protéger
les civils palestiniens en déclarant
dans ce type de combat il parle bien sûr
de guerre urbaine le centre de gravité
c'est la population civile et si vous la
poussez dans les bras de l'ennemi vous
remplacez une victoire tactique par une
défaite stratégique donc on voit bien
que le tonmonte entre contre le
gouvernement
israélien est-ce que il prend le risque
d'une critique mondiale
est-ce que c'est en tout cas ISEN oui
est-ce que c'est la je ne sais pas sil
prend le risque je crois
qu'effectivement il y a un un
mécontentement assez assez grand une
critique assez grande qui n'est pas
universelle par exemple un pays comme
l'Inde qui a toujours été on va dire
assez réservé sur sur le monde musulman
et est plutôt favorable à Israël il y a
des gens qui restent favorable à Israël
mais la la critique est quand même très
très répandue mais le problème d'Israël
c'est le le le seul interlocuteur qui
soit important pour Israël ce sont les
États-Unis d'Amérique faut pas se
tromper c'est ce que si les États-Unis
ont traditionnellement toujours exercé
une influence forte et ont fait plier en
qure des acccords on fait plier Israël
par exemple ne serait-ce que en 56 au
moment de l'affaire de suesse pour
prendre un exemple parmi d'autres mais
il y a eu les opérations de Monsieur
Becker contre chamir et cetera et et et
quand il y a un conflit entre Israël et
les États-Unis Israël dépend trop des
États-Unis pour ne pas pour pour ne ne
pas en tenir compte or aujourd'hui la
question est de savoir si le président
Biden qui a exercé une fonction
modératrice bienvenue mais qui se
retient d'être davantage critique à
l'égard d'Israël et prêt à contraindre
Israël à s'engager sur un processus de
paix qui euh quel qu'en soit les la
forme on va pas il a il y a 1000 il a il
y a 1000 difficultés 1000 mais quel que
soit la forme un processus de paix qui
déboucherait sur une solution à deux
États plus ou moins rapide plus ou moins
complète qui est la chose que le
gouvernement israélien et en particulier
son premier ministre ne veut pas donc là
est l'en jeu c'est pas facile pour Biden
parce que son parti est divisé et que
son opposition trumpiste et on voit voit
que Trump va plutôt le vent en poupe en
ce moment son opposition trumpis serait
évidemment à 100 % pour Isra on va
parler de cette solution à deux état
mais tout d'abord Israël se défend de de
de ces critiques sur une une réponse qui
finalement serait disproportionné ou mal
proportionné en expliquant que l'État
hébreu est une démocratie qui mène une
guerre légitime contre un adversaire qui
veut le détruire on connaît la célèbre
formule de la première ministre Israël
goldamir qui disait en en 1972 je
préfère vos condamnations à vos
condoléances jusqu'à quel point selon
vous cette positionl est-elle
tenable la position d'Israël oui moi je
je crois que le problème d'Israël n'est
pas simplement qui Fa qui fait la guerre
il y a une légitime défense je crois
qu'on peut argumenter ça très solidement
c'est qu'on ne sait pas quelle guerre il
fait quels sont les buts de guerre
d'Israël quel est éradiquer le Hamas
c'est non mais ça ne veut rien dire le
Hamas n'est pas un état le Hamas c'est
un parti politique c'est quelques
milliers de combattants c'est des caches
d'armes c'est quelques vous dites un
parti politique mais c'est aussi
présenté comme un groupe terroriste
comment le Hamas c'est aussi un groupe
terroriste oui c'est un parti politique
terroriste c'est je ne mets pas du tout
ça un groupe terroriste c'est aussi un
parti politique je ne je ne donne pas un
brevet de un brevet de de pacification
de respectabilité à travers ce mot je
vous rassure mais mais mais en revanche
c'est c'est c'est un parti qui et qui
aujourd'hui il faut le reconnaître a
marquer certains points vis-à-vis de la
communauté internationale le point
essentiel c'est que tout le monde se
fichait comme de son premier col marin
de l'affaire palestinienne que ce soit
la communauté internationale les
Américains les Européens les arabes
modérés et cetera personne ne s'en
soucier et ils ont remis à travers ces
horreurs
absolue du 7 octobre ils ont remis le
l'enjeu palestinien au cœur de la
problématique mondiale et de ce point de
vue-là si demain il y avait des
élections en terre palestiniennne il est
pas du tout exclu notamement s Jordanie
qui subit quand même de plein fouet des
une politique de colonisation
extrêmement agressive monsieur Harot
avait employé devant la commission des
affaires étrangères le terme des
puration de dépuration ethnique je crois
que c'est un terme assez violent mais
qui malgré tout désigne une réalité
quand on voit le les centaines de morts
qui ont sont intervenu ces dernières
semaines en en sisjordanie il y a
effectivement quelque chose d'important
alors tout ce mouvement tout ce
mouvement palestinien est actuellement
et c'est très très
problématique derrière le Hamas donc que
veut dire détruire le Hamas détruire
l'appareil militaire de Hamas ce n'est
pas détruire la politique du Hamas la le
véritable véritable problème c'est
qu'une guerre elle n'existe depuis clus
V on sait que la guerre et la
continuation de la politique par
d'autres moyens la guerre elle existe en
fonction de ses objectifs politiques or
je n'ai toujours pas compris et je crois
que personne n'a compris parce que ça
n'a jamais été exprimé quels sont les
les les les objectifs politiques que
poursuit Israël à part le N dit absolu
qui est de faire le
mais ça c'est impossible d'envoyer les
les millions de de de de si Jord de de
Gazaoui en Égypte et les six jordaniens
chez le roi de Jordanie si c'est
évidemment si c'est ça le nom dit c'est
évidemment inimaginable impossible
ingérable Jean-Louis B j'économise cette
cette semaine l'excellent journal
britannique titre is putin winning
traduction est-ce que Poutine est en
train de de de gag l'attention que
porte le monde à la situation au Proche
Orient laisse-t-elle les mains libres en
quelque sorte à à Vladimir Poutine le le
problème moi je je crois que la
tenenstion c'est la tension c'est vrai
que c'est on a eu on a une difficulté
assez grande à se concentrer sur
l'Ukraine depuis le 7 octobre dernier il
reste que le problème numéro 1 c'est pas
celui-là le problème numéro 1 c'est la
politique républicaine la domination
républicaine d'une partie du Congrès aux
États-Unis c'est-à-dire les amis de
Trump qui sont en même temps des amis de
Poutine ils ne le savent pas ils ne le
veulent pas mais Trump est un amis de
Poutine et et et les sénateurs et les
congressman qui soutiennent qui
soutiennent Trump en fait jouent plus ou
moins dans la main de Poutine et on l'a
bien vu dans la
décision le blocage par le Congrès euh
financier notamment ouis
l'raine c'est ça le problème numéro 1
alors c'est indirectement c'est
évidemment il y a des connexion avec ce
qui se passe au Moyen-Orient mais c'est
indépendant il faut je crois qu'on ne
mesure pas suffisamment en France et en
Europe ce que représente le retour
potentiel de Trump et le programme qui a
été qui a été présenté notamment par le
New York Times de Trump est tout à fait
terrifiant c'est un un programme qui
remet en cause les fondements de la
démocratie américaine qui parmi nous
aurait cru que cette démocratie viit
depuis 2 siècles serait à ce point
menacé qui met en cause la solidarité
Atlantique puisque vous le jugez
probable le retour de de écoutz moi je
ne juge pas ce que je vois c'est que les
sondages les sondages donnent 51 48 pour
Monsieur Trump contre 48 pour Monsieur
Biden et dans ce qu'on appelle les swing
States c'est un un avantage partout de
Monsieur monsieur Trump alors je sais
bien qu'il faut se méfier même des
sondages dans les swing States parce que
c'est souvent un compté un autre compté
enfin ça c'est extrêmement fin donc ça
je ne pense pas qu'il fait en tirer une
prédiction mais il est absolument
évident qu'il y a jeu égal entre les
deux candidats ce qui est inimaginable
quelques années après l'affaire du
Capitol il y a jeu égal entre les deux
candidats avec un léger avantage
aujourd'hui pour Donald Trump et ça
c'est un problème et pour les européen
je crois que c'est c'est quelque chose
que je disais il met en cause à travers
le temps l'article 5 c'est-à-dire le la
l'article de solidarité entre les les
membres de l'Alliance et donc pour les
Européens il est absolument impératif de
passer à la vitesse supérieur en terme
d'union en terme de mobilisation en
terme de soutien à l'Ukraine pour
l'instant nous ne sommes pas desbandés
sur l'Ukraine nous continuons à soutenir
l'Ukraine et nous devons absolument euh
continuer cette œuvre et et prendre le
relais si nécessaire des États-Unis qui
ne feront pas à l'avenir ce qu'ils ont
fait dans le passé alors il y a les les
européennes qui qui approchent he c'est
en c'est en juin le parti de la la
majorité n'a toujours pas lancé sa sa
campagne électorale alors qu'on voit
bien que le rassemblement national et
notamment Jordan Bella Bardella lui
ratisse déjà le le le terrain avec des
sondages là pour le coup ù qui est donné
ou qui donne le rassemblement national
en tête est-ce que le parti Renaissance
est en train de faire la même erreur
politique pendant les législatives
c'està-dire prendre du retard et perdre
du temps parti naissance et le nôtre et
le modem et le parti horizon la majorité
n'est pas la
majorité reste reste au vestia alors que
la qu'on est en train de de préparer que
le combat est déjà engagé j'ai été ben
bien sûr que je déplore de toute façon
je déplore profondément que l'enjeu
européen ne soit pas perçu dans toutes
ces dimensions à travers cette élection
si on croit qu'on va dire on va faire
une politique nationale alors on a tous
les ayant droit qui demandent des choses
très légitimes et cetera indépendamment
de l'Europe et puis qu'après à côté on
aura l'Europe on dira il y a ceux qui
sont pour ceux qui sont contre ça ne
marchera pas en réalité ce qu'il faut
que c'est ça l'enjeu véritable c'est que
nos compatriotes français mais également
nos concitoyens européens mesurent que
ce qui se joue à travers les l'enjeu
européen notamment à travers cette
élection ce sont deux choses
essentielles première chose est-ce que
nous allons défendre ce que nous sommes
c'est-à-dire nos valeurs nos principes
nos intérêts notre influence notre
système démocratique notre système
juridique est-ce qu'on va se battre pour
ça on va estimer que bah non il y a
Poutine et deuxièmement est-ce qu'on va
se battre ensemble pour ça c'est deux
enjeux importants tant qu'on a'ura pas
mis ça sur la table on ne pourra pas
nos
concitoyens temp Jean est-ce que
l'institution européenne a jamais su se
rendre séduisante intéressante pour les
citoyens
européens les l'institution européenne
elle a elle a elle marche quand elle a
les moyens d'agir- par exempleemp la
prenons l'exemple de la monnaie la
monnaie la monnaie unique on a créé à
Maastricht un système qui tient debout
on est pour ou contre ça c'est notre
problème mais c'est un système qui tient
debout on a une banque fédérale on a une
monnaie et on a des politique qui anime
cette monnaie et c'est comme ça qu'on
s'en est tiré de difficultés
considérables à travers les crises
successives c'est un exemple quand on a
fait la politique agricole commune du
temps du général le on avait les
instruments ça marchait on on on on fait
je deux exemples je pourrais en prendre
bien d'autres le marché intérieur a
dynamiser en grande partie l'économie
nous avons nous avons mené une politique
extrêmement cohérente en direction de
l'Europe de l'Est regardez ce que ça
donne la Pologne moi j'ai connu la
Pologne en 1989 c'était des gens qui
vivaientent dans la misère et bien 25
ans 35 ans plus tard c'est c'est c'est
le contraire donc mais simplement il
faut que l'Europe ait des moyens or les
états regard comm faut plus de
démocratie européenne par qui plus de
pouvoir la démocratie européenne je ne
crois pas que ce soit contrairement à ce
qu'on dit que l'Europe souffre d'un
déficit de démocratie elle elle elle
elle souffre d'un déficit de moyens
c'est-à-dire beaucoup de décisions
restent pris à l'unanimité or
l'unanimité il faut savoir ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire qu'un état de
quelques millions d'habitants comme la
Hongrie peut bloquer 450 millions
d'habitants estce que unanimité je suis
pas d'accord on prend pas la décision
bon c'est ce que j'ai dit à nos no nos
collègues du rassemblement nationale on
avait un débat sur l'Europe la semaine
dernière dit vous défendez l'unanimité
au nom de la de la grandeur nationale et
de l'indépendance nationale vous ne
voyez pas que l'unanimité est un piège
qui vous paralyse bien davantage qu'il
ne vous aide donc c'est un exemple les
moyens budgétaire reste absolument
dérisoire donc il y a il y a une
réflexion à mener et les les et on
n'aide pas les Français et les Européens
à concevoir ce qu'est l'Europe il faut
répondre clairement pour que les gens
puissent adhérer à ce projet ou le
combattre répondre clairement à trois
questions qui quoi comment qui sont les
Européens quelles sont les frontières
comment que fait-on ensemble non quoi
que fait-on ensemble et que fait-on
séparément dans nos états et comment le
fait-on c'est la question démocratique
or moi je peux vous démontrer que
l'équilibre politique de l'Union
européenne est un équilibre démocratique
où il y a des gens élu au suffrage
universel d'un côté et puis les
gouvernements qui sont aussi élu au
suffrage universel bang on va parler de
la loi immigration qui sera qui sera
examinée en séance à l'Assemblée
nationale à partir de de lundi prochain
d'abord un est-ce que ce texte a des
chances d'obtenir une une majorité et de
euh laissant triste là-dedans puisque
vous vous êtes vous êtes centriste vous
étudiez vous je crois que vous préparez
d'ailleurs un livre depuis longtemps
qu'on a envie de lire sur sur le Centre
et sa position aujourd'hui son à la fois
son histoire et à la fois son rôle
aujourd'hui euh voilà quel quel va être
votre non mais il y a pour la première
question est-ce que ça va aboutir j'en
sais rien ou je crois que ce qui s'est
passé en commission des lois est assez
prometteur c'est-à-dire que en
commission des lois il y a eu un accord
assez grand dans dans ma commission il y
avait certains articles qui ont été
examinés il y a eu un accord qui était
assez grand donc je pense que c'est
c'est c'est c'est pas mal et je pense
que cette loi il faut moi je je la vois
avec beaucoup de de d'humilité c'est
c'est une loi qui améliore les choses
mais c'est pas la loi qui va résoudre
tous les problèmes euh ça compris pour
la M vous êtes d'accord avec ça non mais
ça c'est c'est vraiment extérieur au
sujet ça c'est c'est vraiment extérieur
au sujet non moi je crois que ce qu'on
on a ce qu'on a vu c'est bon il faut
peut-être aller plus dans le détail mais
ce qu'on a vu globalement et les
médecins l'ensemble des l'ensemble du du
du corps médical et des infirmières h
sont très réservés sur l'idée que on
puisse gagner de l'argent en en excluant
un certain nombre de gens de il y a le
rapport
stéphanini evvin qui n'est pas que qui
n'est pas encore publiquement sorti je
crois ou qui est sorti hier en tout cas
je ne l'ai pas lu qui rôle juste pour
finir le rôle des des centristes alors
le rôle des centristes nous nous
estimons que c'est une loi que ce qui
est dans cette loi est bien ne serait-ce
que la simplification la les tas de
mesures pour la formation des des des
des des des migrants pour de qui sont
qui vont dans le bon sens en revanche
nous considérons nous ne sommes pas du
tout dans une approche
répressive de type rassemblement
national nous estimons que il y a un
grand problème qui ne sera pas posé à
travers cette cette loi mais qu' fara
qu'il faudra poser c'est le problème de
à peu près 400000 travailleurs qui sont
qui
travaill qui qui font vivre des secteurs
entiers comme la restauration et qui
n'ont pas le et c'est terminé